Samsung isn't showing a new flagship
phone at this year's Mobile World
Congress in Barcelona they're showing
two of them this is the galaxy s6 and
this is the galaxy s6 edge and both have
a lot of similarities they're both using
higher-quality materials like aluminium
and glass and they both are using those
materials for the name range of bright
and interesting colors in both phones
you're going to find the usual set of
improvements that happen every year
you're going to see faster processors
you're going to see a sharper camera
brighter more vivid displays but one
improvement really does stand out and
that is battery life in both cases you
can charge these phones for 10 minutes
and have enough power to watch 2 hour
movie charge them for 30 minutes and
you'll already be up to 50 percent and
you can now charge both of these phones
wirelessly of the two phones the edge is
by far the more radical one it's curved
display adds extra space to display
things like discreet notifications and
allow you to access frequently contacted
people that side display can also
discreetly notify you when one of your
frequent contacts is calling you you
assign them a specific color and the
phone really glow in that color letting
you know that say your spouse is calling
here's the thing about the high-end of
the smartphone market it keeps getting
higher and samsung has clearly heard
calls for more luxurious devices and
with models like these which will be
coming out in April it's obvious that
they're not seeding the market to anyone